[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint dans
filch l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
cette semaine a été maillé de nombreuses
mobilisations mouvement national contre
le pacte de responsabilité mais aussi
grève dans des sociétés du coin nous
ferons le tour des différentes
mobilisations l'état prêtera 2,6
millions à l'université de Versailles
5anta en Yveline de quoi combler une
partie du déficit budgétaire alors que
la Cour des comptes soulligne de
nombreuses erreurs de gestion ce weekend
se tiendra à Paris le Salon de la
Franchise nous vous proposons pour
l'occasion de découvrir ce modèle
économique nous rencontrerons des
franchisés et des franchiseurs du
département dans notre dossier de la
semaine et puis nous parlerons de la
semaine nationale de l'artisanat les
responsables de la chambre des métiers
de l'artisanat sont actuellement dans
les haut de scènes il s'excuse pour l'un
des nombreux événements organisés cette
semaine mais nous avons pu retrouver
Daniel varly le président de la Chambre
ce midi ainsi que math de jacquem de
l'Institut des métiers qui nous a parlé
innovation nous écouterons leurs
interviews dans l'entretien tout de
suite place à l'actualité économique de
la
semaine
à l'appel de la CGT de FO de solidaire
une manifestation s'est déroulée mardi
contre le pacte de responsabilité
proposé en début d'année par le
gouvernement plusieurs départs ont eu
lieu vers Paris dont un att trpe nous y
avons rencontré les salariés mobilisé
dont Jean-Michel Chéron de l'union
locale CGT on l'appelle Pact de
responsabilité mais c'est un éniè plan
de de pour l'emploi avec des aides
supplémentaires à un patronat qui qui
utilise les aides pour pour faire autre
chose que pour créer de l'emploi donc ça
va pas arranger y compris que ça va même
aggraver les choses parce qu'avec cet
argent là ils vont faire autre chose et
il y a aussi toutes les raisons qui nous
poussent aujourd'hui à agir dans les
entreprises et y compris descendre dans
la rue par rapport au au simples liberté
dans l'entreprise le respect du Code du
travail des gens qui souffrent dans
l'entreprise qui soient ouvriers
employés cadres ingénieurs tous ces
gens-là ont une pression inadmissible
dans les entreprises
le mouvement a donc réuni 10000
personnes selon la police 40000 selon
les organisateurs un bilan donc assez
mitigé après leur mouvement des 14 et 28
février dernier et le silence de la
direction les salariés d'Aka technologie
s'apprêtent à nouveau à manifester ce
vendredi devant les sièges social de
l'entreprise à Boulogne billancour les
employés basés à Guy encour proteste
donc toujours contre la modification du
barê de remboursement des frais
professionnels il il perd entre 300 et
900 € par mois selon les cas à noté qu'
technologie a fait état d'un chiffre
d'affaires de 231,1 million d'euros au
4e trimestre en repli cependant de 1,6 %
mais le groupe a légèrement dépassé son
objectif de 875 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires annuel je propose
d'écouter les revendications du
personnel n ce qu'on voudrait c'est
renégocier le un barè qui soit vraiment
comment dirais-je vraiment un V du
salarié l'idéal si vous voulez pour nous
ça serait ré vous savez aujourd'hui
puisque l'argumentation de dire
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle veut se mettre
en conformité avec l'URSAF et si vous
voulez l'URSAF si la société don 150 €
aujourd'hui un salari si le salarié
justifie les 150 € pour LEF il y a aucun
problème puisque justifie donc nous on
dit si vraiment c'est de se mettre en
conité ave le SAF pass tout me offrire
simplement tout ça un cooup pour la
société parce qu'aujourd'hui en fin de
compte vraiment le nouveau barê c'est
vra une mesure
d'économie autre manifestation celle des
salariés de dbold à Guy encour ce lundi
les équipes techniques de la société
américaine en charge du fonctionnement
des distributeurs de billets sont en
colère suite à un réaménagement du temps
de travail ils étaient une vingtaine
mobilisé donc ce lundi pour faire valoir
leur mécontentement auprès de leur
direction devant les sièges de
l'entreprise explication avec un
représentant syndical CFDT au micro de
Romain
grabet fa parce que ça fait presque un
an maintenant en avril 2013 que la
direction a décidé de négocier revoir
les aménagements de temps de travail
donc en demandant à ce que les
techniciens travaillent non plus sur une
base de 9 jours par quinzaine et sur 10
jours donc perdre 24 jours de repos et
actuellement nos temps de trajet sont
considérés comme du temps de travail
effectif de là ils ont décidé de de
supprimer les les repos donc 24 jours
c'est en en en temps homme ben ça fait 7
emploi ils ont décidé de de supprimer
les temps de trajet ce qui va leur
permettre de faire travailler les gens
jusqu'à 13h par
jour alors la société de débit dbol de
France n'a pas souhaité répondre à nos
demandes d'interview elle a reçu les
représentants le lundi mais ne voulait
pas entamer de négociation tant que le
mouvement de grève débuté le 11 mars
n'était pas terminé alors les les
salariés ont accepté cette demande ils
ont été reçus donc par la Direction ont
commencé des négociations elles sont
toujours en cours et nous sommes donc en
attente de leur nouvelles et puis pour
finir sur ces mobilisations Notter
également aujourd'hui une manifestation
des douaniers mais également des
intermittents du spectacle qui se sont
retrouvés cet après-midi à
Paris l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yveline est sauvé ou
tout du moins à court terme l'État a
annoncé qu'il verserait une avance
remboursable de 2,6 million d'euros
alors en décembre dernier le ministère
de l'enseignement supérieur avait déjà
versé 800000 € cette annonce est tombé
en tout cas en même temps que le rapport
de la Cour des comptes il n'est pas bon
il couvre la période
2006-22 et reprend des critique que l'on
avait déjà entendu lors de la découverte
du déficit de ce budget opération de
partenariat public privé mal géré
augmentation mal maîtrisée des emplois
ou encore un retour excessif aux heures
supplémentaires surtout elle doute de la
sincérité des estimations budgétaires en
tout cas des mesures de réduction des
coûts seront évidemment à prendre à
censcir l'école un projet écologique est
sur le point d'être achevé 34 logements
sociaux en bois sont Act actuellement
pardon en construction rue Victor
bachche à deux pas du RER coût de
l'opération pour le bailleur environ 6,3
million d'euros un coût qui devrait
cependant être amorti dans le futur
grâce aux économies des énergie Sabrina
sikini et elodan ont visité le
site un chantier en apparence comme les
autres ou presque car dans ces
constructions d'HLM en cours à saincir
l'école on pense avant tout
développement durable ici la structure
des immeubles est réalisé en bois le
bois déjà un coefficient d'isolation qui
est plus important que le
béton dès que vous touchez du bois c'est
bon il fait pas froid vous touchez du
béton c'est froid ce sont des des des
bâtiments qui sont très très bien isolés
pour travailler dans le sens de
l'économie
d'énergie et aussi utiliser une une
énergie qui est renouvelable le bois on
fait pousser les arbres on les coupe on
construit avec on refit pousser un autre
arbre le béton
on on tire toujours dans les énergies
fossiles Yann Brunel tient sa
connaissance du bois d'un long séjour en
Scandinavie pour lui la construction de
ce type d'habitation collective est
appelée à se développer dans l'Hexagone
selon lui le bois permet une économie
d'énergie d'environ 20 % par rapport au
béton le bailleur lui a en tout cas été
sensible à ce procéd on est entré dans
une démarche de développement durable
dans les années 2000 et donc on cherche
avant tout à faire des économies
d'énergie des économies de de ressources
et limiter les consommations les les les
productions de de gaz à effet de serre
donc le bois c'est un matériau qui
répond à toutes ces problématiques c'est
le seul matériau de construction qui est
durable et qui est naturel autre
démarche en faveur de l'écologie
installation de panneaux solaires qui
permettra aux familles de réaliser des
économies 60 % de l'eau chaude sera
autofinancé grâce au sola thermique les
occupants ne devront financer que les 40
% restants un gain non négligeable pour
les futurs locataires qui devraient
ameménager d'ici 3
mois la semaine de l'artisanat se
poursuit lancée vendredi dernier elle
est ponctuée d'événements qui permettent
de mettre en avant les artisans et de
faire connaître cette filière lundi la
chambre de Versailles organisée une
remise de prix du travail pour
récompenser certains de leurs membres
des images de Patrick et Jacques de
dixmud et Jonathan
villman lundi adellino et une
soixantaine d'autres artisans ont reçu
la médaille du travail des mains du
président de la Chambre des métier et de
l'Artisanat de bronze d'argent ou d'or
selon l'ancienneté elle récompense des
carrières réussies et un investissement
dans leur secteur d'activité peut-être
une reconnaissance compte tenu des des
formations professionnelles que j'ai
fait
puisque j'ai formé on va dire
une une bonne quarantaine de d'élèves
qui ont tous eu d'ailleurs leur examen
une reconnaissance pour Adelino ce
peintre décorateur a reçu la médaille de
bronze Manuella elle n'en revient pas
elle pense déjà à sa retraite et sa
médaille d'argent lui permet de finir sa
carrière en beauté très très Amu euh
j'avais presque les larmes aux
yeux car bah j'ai rien fait pour ça on
est venu me voir si on est venu la voir
c'est que l'on ne postule pas à cette
récompense on est choisi par ses pères
ou par la chambre mais alors qu'est-ce
qu'un artisan médaillé accompli pour le
savoir nous avons retrouvé Manuella dans
son salon de morbas pour pas montrer la
technique de la permanente et des
rouleau sur moi ce rapport avec les
clients est l'un des aspects de son
travail qu'elle aime tout
particulièrement ça fait 22 ans que je
vois souvent les mêmes personnes surtout
le vendredi je vois toujours les mêmes
personnes donc
c'est c'est un peu la
famille et pourtant rien ne l'a
prédestiné à s'engager dans cette voie
en 1972 à 15 ans elle quitte son
Portugal natal pour la France et vit
alors de petit boulot pendant un an j'ai
fait du ménage et ça me convenait pas
parce que j'étais rachétique et et à
chaque fois j'avais des problèmes de
santé et alors j'ai commencé dans la
coiffure et c'était une roue de secours
mais qui m'a beaucoup plu
ne parlant pas français elle ne passe
alors qu'un cap chose courante dans les
années 70 mais lorsqu'elle veut ouvrir
son propre salon on lui explique qu'il
lui faut un diplôme supplémentaire un
brevet professionnel pendant 20 ans elle
embauche des détenteurs de ce diplôme
pour être en règle avant de se décider à
le passer à 56 ans pour moi c'était
vraiment je sais que bon ben je vais
bientôt arrêter mais c'est un plus c'est
c'est une récompense c'est c'est génial
fin de carrière réussie pour manuel qui
cherche aujourd'hui un
[Musique]
repreneur et on continue avec cette
semaine de l'artisanat nous allons faire
le point avec Daniel varly le président
de la Chambre il ne pouvait être présent
aujourd'hui ce soir plutôt sur notre
plateau nous l'avons donc retrouvé ce
midi monsieur Varl bonjour on célèbre la
semaine nationale de l'artisanat alors
finalement quel est son but
la semaine nationale de l'artisanat
semaine où on met en avant les qualités
de l'artisanat vous savez cette première
entreprise de France la plus grosse
entreprise auquel nos artisans sont
parsemés partout puis on représente 50 %
des entreprises en France donc voyez
l'importance de la représentativité de
ce tissu économique économique et social
qu'on pourrait dire aussi puisque c'est
des toutes petites entreprises le but
c'est de mettre en valeur finalement ces
artisans et puis peut-être aussi
d'attirer de nouvelles recrues abument
c'est déjà de pouvoir que les gens
puissent sidentifier ce que c'est qu'une
qu'un artisan qu'une entreprise
artisanale et puis après vous savez
qu'on est plein de passion plein de
volonté et que nous formons aussi donc
c'est pour mettre en avant toutes ces
qualités qu'on peut qu'on peut trouver
dans l'artisanat alors vous cherchez
aussi à montrer qu'il y a de nouveaux
profils d'artisans quels sont-ils
absolument les artisans point de vue
technologie sont à la base de toutes les
réussites industrielles donc commence
par faire une petite pièce qui va servir
dans n'importe quel domaine et c'est
donc là aussi un monde méconnu de
l'artisanat je pense aussi à de nouveaux
profils des personnes plus diplômées
finalement l'apprentissage attire de
plus en plus aujourd'hui absolument
l'apprentissage est ouvert à toute la
gamme de de personnes mais on voit aussi
maintenant nous avons des des jeunes
diplômés ça soit dans le développement
durable que ça soit dans les
technologies tous ces gens qui viennent
de l'artisanat font des vacs ils ont des
niveaux 4 des niveaux 3 c'est vraiment
des gens performants alors dans les
Yvelines combien y a-t-il d'artisans et
dans quel secteur les Yvelines 17000
artisans dans le secteur du bâtiment 44
% 36 % dans le secteur des services il y
a 11 % dans le secteur de la fabrication
et on est à peu près 8 % dans le secteur
de l'alimentation voilà le ce que
représente l'artisanat ilinois est-ce
que c'est un chiffre en ha Haus est-ce
que ces artisans vont bien
ici les artisans souffrent néanmoins de
cette crise je dirais
plus principalement dans le dans le
domaine du bâtiment un domaine du
bâtiment qui est vraiment touché euh et
on pour en avoir encore échangé cette
semaine avec des
représentants on a peine à voir le le
bout du tunnel les services aussi ont
été vraiment impactés puisque on va un
petit peu moins chez le coiffeur on va
un petit peu moins chez l'esthéticienne
t les services à la personne donc les
services sont impactés cependant
l'alimentaire retrouve je dirais une
marge de manœuvre tout à fait correct
puisque le les gens par souci de
sécurité et par besoin de conseil
retourne chez son artisan de proximité
merci beaucoup je vous en prie à bientôt
et puis ce midi nous en avons également
profité pour rencontrer Mathilde jacquem
de l'Institut supérieur des métiers pour
parler innovation ma ja par vos
fonctions au sein l'Institut Supérieur
des métiers vous êtes spécialisé dans
l'innovation pour les petites
entreprises et pour l'artisana c'était
l'objet de la conférence d'aujourd'hui
alors justement à quoi doit-on s'adapter
comment innou aujourd'hui les
entreprises doivent s'adapter à leur
consommateur avant tout et aujourd'hui
le consommateur c'est un consomacteur
c'est un individu qui se renseigne sur
les réseaux sociaux sur Internet qui
prend des avis qui compare les prix et
donc il faut s'adapter à ces à ses
usages sur le Web qu'il a et qui se sont
généralisés alors comment justement
s'installer sur le web quand on est
artisan ça passe par les plateformes
Facebook site internet ou ou ça passe
par d'autres moyens bah déjà le le
premier moyenais ce sont les les pages
jaunes il faut se faire référencer sur
les pages jaunes sur Google il faut
éventuellement se doter d'un site
internet d'un site de e-commerce il faut
être actif sur les réseaux sociaux donc
il faut utiliser toutes sortes de moyens
en fonction de de ces moyens financiers
et de ces moyens en temps s'adapter donc
par le web pour être plus en contact
finalement avec les utilisateurs les
consommateurs mais ça passe aussi par
les nouvelles technologies ah oui
complètement ça passe par les nouvelles
technologie mais évidemment à un moment
donné on peut être en face du du
consommateur et à ce moment-là il faut
aussi être innovant dans sa manière
d'être en relation avec lui et
aujourd'hui on a on est face à un
consommateur qui demande toujours des
services en plus il est plus que il est
roi plus que jamais disons et ça on peut
lui répondre à ses
demandes oui on peut répondre à ces
demandes il suffit du du petit plus ça
passe par le le bon sens et par la
qualité de la relation humaines qu'on
est capable de mettre de mettre en place
s'adapter au consommateurs c'est
s'adapter donc à des consommateurs très
connectés et c'est finalement à
s'adapter aussi à des consommateurs qui
vieillissent à une population plus
vieillissante oui tout à fait c'est une
tendance lourde de la société on sait
qu'elle elle est en train de vieillir
donc ça représente un marché colossal
pour demain et notamment pour les
artisans car il va falloir adapter
l'habitat des personnes âgées pour que
puissent se maintenir à domicile le plus
longtemps possible mais ça concerne
toutes sortes d'artisans parce que il
faut adapter aussi les les aliments les
les pâtisseries les produits
détraiteurs ça concerne tous les les
services à la personne également
s'adresser à un une personne
vieillissante c'est pas la même chose
que s'adresser à un consommateur comme
vous et moi en parfaite santé s'adapt à
ces populations est-ce qu'il y a un
autre d'autres moyens d'adaptation autre
les technologies le web le type de
population oui alors après on peut
inventer un nouveau produit hein on a
cet exemple qui a un peu défrayé la la
chronique ces derniers mois c'est le
fameux cronuts qui nous vient des des
États-Unis c'est un un boulanger
français qui a inventé cette recette qui
mélange le donut et le le croissant il
appelé ça cronuts et c'est devenu un
espèce de de produit super à la mode et
qui le fait connaître le fait connaître
parce qu'il est très connecté lui-même
il est sur Facebook il a un très beau
site internet il présente aussi très
bien il faut le dire donc c'est un
ensemble de
choses très bien ben on espère que les
artisans du coup pouront entendre vos
conseils
merci
à l'approche du salon de la franchise
qui sera organisé ce weekend à Paris je
vous propose d'aller à la rencontre de
franchisé et de franchiseur du
département de quoi s'agit-il quel est
l'intérêt de la franchise le dossier de
la semaine est réalisé avec Jonathan
villman et Patrick Jacques de dixm
Philippe s'est lancé dans la
création d'entreprise il y a 3 ans il
est aujourd'hui à la tête de ce magasin
de coignère spécialisé dans le matériel
de piscine spa et arrosage un changement
de vie radical pour cette an cien
salarié spécialisé dans le développement
et la vente à l'international de
produits
électromécaniques depuis longtemps ben
j'avais envie de mettre à mon compte de
faire quelque chose pour moi et la
piscine a toujours été un petit peu une
une passion à titre privé donc j'ai
connu h jardin en tant que client dans
un premier temps et euh ça m'a amené
effectivement à à m'intéresser à la à la
franchise parce que ça me paraissait un
bon moyen de de démarrer une activité
qui m'était bah totalement inconnu euh
au démarrage et de pouvoir mettre toutes
les chances de de mon côté Philippe ne
souhaitait pas se lancer seul et partir
de zéro avec le système de la franchise
il a pu profiter de l'accompagnement du
franchiseur des méthodes de travail les
bons contacts au niveau des fournisseurs
ou encore des informations sur les
produits et puis c'est aussi une
enseigne qui a qui a pignon sur rue donc
tout de suite vous êtes connu ou reconnu
vous êtes pas un étranger ou un inconnu
dans dans dans un secteur quoi pour
bénéficier de ces avantages le franchisé
doit remplir certaines conditions la
première payer un droit d'entrée
c'est-àdire le droit de porter le nom de
la marque Philippe a payé 13500 € mais
selon les secteurs ce prix varie
deuxième coup les royalties un
pourcentage du chiffre d'affaires
réalisé qui vise à payer les différents
services et outils mis à disposition par
le franchiseur ici 3,86 %. ces tarifs
sont inscrits dans un contrat établi
entre le Fran ur et le franchisé est
limité dans le temps c'est temps pour
Philippe il figure également les
obligations du franchisé par exemple le
respect du concept de l'enseigne parfois
il y a des des approches ou des
évolutions au niveau de certaines gammes
de produits ou ou du concept en lui-même
ou on aimerait bien avoir un petit peu
plus de liberté c'est un petit peu
l'aspect négatif parce qu'on est pas
complètement indépendant mais bon on a
quand même encore un petit peu de
l'attitude donc ça va
pour se former à la méthode du
franchiseur le jeune entrepreneur aura
suivi une formation de 6 mois une partie
au siège et une partie dans des magasins
du groupe la marque faite cette année
c'estes 25 ans elle possède aujourd'hui
82 magasins en France dont près d'une
soixantaine de franchisé car depuis 2004
la direction a décidé de se développer
via la franchise et non plus en ouvrant
des magasins en propre une stratégie
partagée par cette enseigne de la grande
distribution elle représente 12 % de
l'activité 61 magasins franchisés contre
252 en propre un moyen de se développer
rapidement et à moindsre frais et de
mutualiser les dépenses ce sont dans
tous les cas des volumes supplémentaires
qui concourent à l'écrasement d'un
certain nombre de coûts parce que ça
c'est un L motif permanent dans notre
secteur d'activité écraser les coûts on
a des coûts importants des coûts de
transport importants des coûts de
personnel importants d'une manière
générale dans les magasins donc tout ce
qui concourt à écraser les couts apporte
sa contribution à l'amélioration des
performances parmi les franchises on
compte d'anciens salariés de l'enseigne
qui ont souhaité se mettre à leur compte
mais aussi de nouvelles recrues pour
ouvrir sa franchise il faut du temps un
an environ mais avant cela la sélection
est rude le premier critère une bonne
connaissance du secteur ensuite il faut
qu'on arrive à identifier chez les
candidats la capacité à devenir chef
d'entreprise puisque ça c'est un
paramètre extrêmement important et enfin
disposer malgré tout de moyens
financiers parce que ce sont des
investissements qui sont relativement
lourds même s'il y a plusieurs schémas
de montage d'opération il est quand même
nécessaire de disposer de fonds minimum
bon aujourd'hui en ce qui nous concerne
l'apport minimable est de l'ordre de
300000 € pour monter une opération
sécurisée ici pas de droit d'entrée mais
des fonds nécessaires pour acheter un
local et l'aménager les royalties
autrement dit les redevances pour
l'enseigne et la publicité s'élèvent à 4
% du chiffre d'affaires hors taxe que le
franchisé soit indépendant et détiennent
un ou plusieurs de leurs magasins ne
pose pas de problème car en règle
générale un franchisé est plus
performant il y a une stabilité plus
forte dans les hommes et il y a une
intégration dans le tissu local plus
forte que dans nos magasins en propre où
les collaborateurs sont salariés et
parfois on arrive pas toujours à obtenir
la même motivation la même implication
le même investissement sur ce sur ces
paramètres donc ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on observe effectivement dans la
durée à la Fédération Française de la
Franchise on soutient également cette
idée d'une performance plus importante
on cite de manière régulière un chiffre
qui est de 80 % de de réussite en
franchise comparé à à peu près 50 %
quand on crée son entreprise seule donc
effectivement l'effet réseau est
important c'est aussi une des
obligations du franchiseur de trouver
des solutions quand comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui la situation économique est
un petit peu tendue la Fédération créée
en 1971 regroupe aujourd'hui plus de 150
réseaux adhérents soit 45 % des
franchisés français son rôle faire le
lien entre les pouvoirs publics les
franchiseurs les entrepreneurs et
investisseurs pour promouvoir ce
modeentrepreneuriat la France a gardé
son avance on est à plus de 1700 réseaux
de franchise donc ça ce sont les
chiffres à à janvier
2014 plus de
65000 franchisés et et et ça progresse
de manière régulière depuis une
vingtaine d'années maintenant voilà donc
c'est un vrai secteur d'activité à part
entière la franchise n'est tout de fois
pas la assurance d'une création
d'entreprise réussie les échecs existent
c'est le cas par exemple pour l'ancien
propriétaire du magasin de Philippe on a
repris un magasin qui qui végéter un
petit peu on a su le le rebooster
développer la la clientèle c'est vrai
qu'on a connu un un petit palier l'année
dernière bah suite aux conditions
météorologiques qui ont pas été
favorables dans le monde de la piscine
mais cette année ça repart bien et ben
moi je dirais que je suis sur un projet
d'avoir un deuxième magasin quoi il
devrait ouvrir prochainement à chartre
la franchise concerne tous les secteurs
sauf l'artisanat et le luxe qui ne
peuvent pas ou ne souhaitent pas
déléguer leur
activité et c'est la fin de ce filcho
merci de nous avoir suivi je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée et vous
donne rendez-vous la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine
I